hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the horrible place
in the middle of the ocean that is raft
now this is an updated version of the
game I'm late to the party but I'm gonna
play it anyway because it's version 1.0
5 instead of version 1.0 4 and a lot of
stuff has apparently been added to the
game so I'm gonna encapsulate the
entirety of loneliness that is my own
sanity whenever I go into this world
than I live in this is um I'm like dead
I'm like dead II I'm pretty I'm like
dead II guys I'm pretty dead I'm pretty
sure that uh this ain't gonna go well
for me Oh at least I got my hook
so the difference being I don't know
what the [ __ ] the difference is but I
know that Wayne Brady ain't dead no more
because I'm starting over again I gotta
build my loneliness perch to be able to
declare my loneliness to the nobody
that's around me oh hey Wayne Brady am I
not gonna get all there's one floating
frond of something oh there it is hey
Wayne Wayne how you been man I'm a big
fan there's not a big fan of you biting
the ass my boat oh also some people
pointed out that I was dumb I know
happens all the time but solid pointed
out that I was dumb and ooh
and I need to you're just gonna pick
that I'm not pick that Wayne don't do
that Wayne Wayne okay alright let's try
that again without being dumb I can't
pick up and swim at the same time
apparently gotcha
oh did you see that there are you
impressed by me yet Wayne Wayne Chan
Wayne senpai damn it
when will Brady senpai notice me ha I'm
gonna be farming for a bit because
obviously I got to get back I don't want
you guys to be like where's the progress
markiplier we came here for competent
raft gameplay yeah and not to watch you
lose your mind like an idiot in the
middle of the ocean why would we do that
that are you stupid
oh wait yes you are and lonely haha yeah
we know
I get it the insults hurt my feelings
and emotions i-i-i in my hypothetical
scenario i actually hurt my own feelings
just there and i actually feel I feel
sad now but I'm gonna just I'm gonna
just do this the best I can
Oh skadoosh key and then oh yeah
wait I forgot to even talk about why you
guys were saying I was stupid
oh yeah so some people I don't know why
I don't know why why why advice dude
mystery mystery to everybody no one
knows it's an enigma I built all of my
valuable stuff my cooker my water
purifier my other things I was tired of
no idea what they are but I built them
all like on one square like if this was
my only square I built them all right
there instead of in the middle where
Wayne couldn't bite the ass off of all
my economy so yeah I'm not gonna do I
guess this time maybe Wayne but I'm
gonna kill him ah no that's good I'm not
gonna kill Wayne Brady I want to kill
that shark whose name happens to be
Wayne Brady
that'll give me of court yeah that'll go
well for me so long story way too long
introduction and story short short I'm
dumb I'll be right back as I expertly
Wayne are you doing Wayne Wayne Wayne
Wayne Wayne little too close to their
body boo little too close I don't
appreciate that I know you're not a
stranger so stranger danger doesn't
apply but you can still shut the [ __ ] up
I'll hook you [ __ ] does Wayne Brady
have to choke a [ __ ] or choke yourself
alright do I have enough to start
building do I do I do I have it have I
got it Oh chop down trees I see how you
do okay so I need to make this blip-blip
blip-blip done I need to make this one
nail
these two cans I probably need that base
material I was standing lantern or chair
that'll go perfectly on my loneliness
porch yes
it's genius would have [ __ ] I didn't
funk
I don't funk anything I got this about
fish down look at Bay on fishing hey
fish get in my mouth and then go out my
ass because that's how eating works
gimme all right I got a raw mackerel I'm
gonna eat that
I [ __ ] goddamn it I'll hit you with
my hammer I'll fish you out of the ocean
[ __ ] you think oh you think you can
just eat oh and my [ __ ] well Frick
you I don't have enough to defend from
you so all I've got are insults I'm the
Internet I can't actually do anything
give me more metal I know I know I'm
dying I know I know it's my everyday
life I get it right there that's a good
that's a good one that's the best one
okay good thing I got three awesome okay
put this on alright I'll gather more
[ __ ] survival more like I'm bored I
apologize my humor is normally top-notch
and that was this subpar I I'm at fault
I feel like we're all at fault for you
do you guys allow him to stab right is
this done yet oh the sun's gonna go down
I don't remember the Sun going down last
time I remember it being all day all day
long
hey Wayne are you doing you want me to
stab you you want me to I'll do it you
know I don't want it you're asking for
it give me one more piece of metal I
need to make oh whoa I am dying I'm
dying
pick up drinkable water drink this water
right now oh boy drink it I drank it I
think okay I think I drank that okay now
is this going bad for me so I'm gonna
make I'm gonna eat this yum yum
goody goody gumdrops okay so I just need
to make another well I need to make a
spear first cuz I'm gonna die if Wayne
Brady comes back on me I'm gonna also
eat that potato raw hell yeah
that's good stuff come to me come to
Papa all right well at least I'm doing a
little bit better
I just need one piece of [ __ ] I don't
think there's a day/night cycle before
well then again as I've reiterated on
give me some metal do you have metal
anybody wants metal for me no no you
don't what about a lantern that's a neat
thing that oh god damn it Wayne Brady
[ __ ] off hey dick right in the eye yeah
[ __ ] off Wayne Brady huh cool
no no I'm gonna do this I'm gonna put
this oh yeah hell yeah bro look out bro
hell yeah bro okay so Savin cook
all right you took up baby boo you cook
up I know I know I'm not healthy
la-dee-da I'm gonna put a potato in a
plant water cook that oh mackerel oh
hell yeah in my belly okay put that over
there get some good fish me come on and
me now hey get in me okay cool good
cooperate all right finally it's the
break Don and I can see [ __ ] like see
Wayne Brady's still being an [ __ ]
over there you want to stop being an
[ __ ] for two seconds Wayne Brady ha
ha
don't make me call Ryan Stiles don't
make me I'll do it
I don't want to do it but I'll do it Lum
num okay hey my heart going back up baby
I feel love again what was that I just
see well fatigue I'm not in the water
come on what do you think I'm doing
I see mental over there I'm gonna get
you I'm getting you finally okay I think
I got more scrap now so I'm out dave is
imma build
I'm gonna build around my thing just
like this I'm smart guys I'm smart I'm
defending come look at me we got smart I
am
see you got you see you guys I'm gonna
get that I built that just get the scram
look guys I'm smart look look how smart
I am
guys look out smart I am baby hi hi hi
Blaine god damn it Wayne
don't make me do this Wayne stop it I'm
gonna kill you and I don't want that I
don't want that don't make me want it
you know don't tease me
I just wish people would ask for what
they want stop hinting at it okay
alright okay I got more rope now okay so
I got my rope I can build more nets
which would be hey Wayne why are you
doing white wine Wayne I know you want
my mackerel but stop it
Wayne this is a little too much I can't
handle this when you're a bit of it
you're an ass haha alright I'm trying to
pull trying to get a quintuple pull here
baby yeah oh yeah oh is that a quintuple
pull oh what's that you're saying they
would have gone in my net anyway
well alright you're a you're crazy
person cuz that one didn't alright
didn't then either okay alright just
gonna keep flailing like a madman thank
you thank you for that okay umm I guess
I could make another planter but I don't
want to do a whole lot I need a storage
I need a chest hell yeah I need a chest
oh hell yeah okay that's good that's the
first time I've leveled up to be able to
get a chest so about put this chest up
valuables right by my oh never mind
right why my how does it open does it
open that way I don't know I'll put it
right by my lanterns but not in the way
there okay that's a good spot I like
that so now I've got a jest that I can
store stuff on my extra wouldn't [ __ ]
all me would I'm gonna get so much crap
now that I got all this net nothing but
net got it yeah that's a wide guy yeah
Wayne you're going for the net put those
down stop it hey [ __ ] come on a few
more steps you're a dead shark man okay
so I'm pretty much back to where I
should have been I know you've been
listening to me blab for the last 15 10
min
I don't know how long but hey I finally
gotten back to where I need to be does
that mean it's the end of the episode
no course is not I haven't dealt what
have I done nothing but bark will is
that ever stopped you from ending an
episode before sure right I shouldn't be
mad at you what now I'm a change I'm not
the irony of me laughing at that is not
it's not lost on me I'm a changed man I
swear I swear I'm a changed man
stop stop laughing it's not funny I've
changed man I'm I'm here for content I'm
here for skill I'm here to show you how
good I can be at games that's why I'm
here all about guys well you don't
believe me
oh you're so smart and idiot again okay
rotate that way that's a better way to
do it put that there am I even this out
of these let's can't fix them that's the
way it is it's the imperfections are
what make it beautiful right that's what
happens right okay what am i making I'm
making a ramp that's right stairs take
me to other floors of course that's
that's why we do these things that we do
rotate that oh yeah oh that's nice oh
that's good what I want I don't think
that's what I want I think this is what
I want
hang on let me just I have no rope get
me rope damn it okay which way is
correct
not that way that this and that Wayne
what are you doing you getting jealous I
know I got a lot going on for me I'm uh
getting begging this spear so I'm I do
here is I gotta I the only thing I
really want to make is my loneliness
birch which is like obviously that's the
only thing I want to do whatever the
hell I need right now I don't even know
what is that's good pillars boink okay
got a pillar now I need to make another
fundation
oh okay got that now I need to make a
Fleur let me make that right there okay
huh blue okay all right I think this is
coming together it's almost there not
quite
needs a little more homely touch before
I'm done with this oh that's good okay I
got my loneliness birch can I sit down
on that I'll just stand on it you know
standings as good as sitting in my book
yeah yeah look upon my kingdom and [ __ ]
you Wayne Brady that's what I wanna say
on my first decree on my lonliness perch
and also I just want to do a few quick
things right here to no one cuz no one's
here I am lonely I just want to say you
bet Wayne Wayne I Wayne Wayne god damn
it Wayne I know I won't oh you're dead
now oh what's that
oh oh you tried and then you died Oh
what does that say about ya
alright now that I'm officially lonely
and I have absolutely no friends which
is what I wanted from the beginning
everybody can go away here so now that
everybody has settled down I'm gonna
take my little piece of Wayne Brady here
and use it as a blunt instrument to make
my point on my lonliness perch alright
now listen up this time don't don't
don't don't do nothing you're gonna
regret okay okay I have no one beside me
there is no one I can call my own
everyone I've known and loved didn't die
they put me in the middle of the ocean
because I was insufferable because they
couldn't take it anymore because I'm
annoying to the point where people want
to die whatever I'm just letting you all
know this no one so that you can
understand my feelings
cuz sharing emotions shouldn't be
punishable by placement on a raft okay
alright then hey look stuff that's
almost as good as friends
I need up increased production because
not meetin standards i'ma put this I'm
gonna make him counter want this to each
other I like the word counter without
the good one all right let's put this
one capsicum that's gonna be hard to
collect oh I didn't I didn't make that
efficient at all good great exactly what
I was hoping for all right is Wayne
Brady back yet oh there's Wayne Brady
oh okay too good to stay dad oh okay
that's what they told me when I tried to
be alive and look what happened to me
and the middle of the ocean with no
friends so you should consider yourself
lucky idiot no one of these all right
where should this one go oh I know
you know I've never really explored the
possibility of nighttime loneliness so
that's that's a thing I'd like to do
[Music]
let's make that improbable who's not
dead didn't work all right you know I'm
good for that boink okay that's a team
stable good to have fire right by my my
boat made of wood yum yum Oh Wayne Brady
tasted good all right so I got potaters
blam blam blam blam blam blam blam blam
okay we're good glad I did that that was
it sure that definitely makes all my
suffering seem worth it here in the open
ocean with nobody to hold me tight at
night and call me Lucy hey don't
question mine I won't question yours
looking for somebody to call me Lucy and
hold me tight so hard good things are
looking up I mean they're not looking up
I'm still just as lonely as ever and sad
but you know I've grown accustomed to it
I don't think you know I don't think I
don't think people need other people in
this world I think they just need their
little piece of Wayne Brady the clone of
Wayne Brady over there or is that Greg
Proops
Greg Greg right oh it's Greg it's Greg
guy he's coming right for it Greg Greg
Proops oh man yeah I'm a big family if
you could stop that and go to hell I'd
like that a lot okay so Wayne Brady's
dead I hate him every bit of them use
losers oh wait one more morsel oh those
good stuff so I'm just gonna be up here
on my lonliness perch and now I've got a
good platform with which to keep playing
this game maybe if it decides to keep
the save files but I bet it will
you know that's good that's good you
guys want to see more of this oh I'll
lose my mind a little more on camera for
you that's not too bad I do it every
videos different so thank you everybody
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this so let me know how I did in gums
blow and what you want to see maybe I'll
spell out I'm lonely and just raft
boards all along the ocean so that
everybody from space when they're having
time about me can't see how lonely I am
so thank you everybody again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
goodbye son you're leaving me too I see
alright goodbye